- [James Bond] I admire your courage, Mr.-
- Trench,
Sylvia Trench.
I admire your luck, Mr.-
- Bond,
James Bond.
(upbeat music)
- Not only is the name iconic,
you see what I did there?
It was a lot of fun.
It's one of the greatest
lines in action movie history.
Bond,
Jimmy Bond.
I'm sorry, I just don't find myself worthy
of saying the actual name of 007.
As a matter of fact, only
six men in the history
of the universe have had the honor
of playing the legendary
super spy, James Bond.
Some are still acting, some
enjoying their golden years,
and some have passed on.
But for today's show,
we're bringing them all out
of retirement for one last mission
should they choose to accept it.
Oh, right. That's the-
that's the other one.
- What are you talking about?
- This is not gonna end well.
- Today we'll figure out once and for all,
or at least until the
next movie comes out,
who is the greatest bond
in cinematic history?
The gold Bond, if you
will, vying for the title
of a medicated powder, is the OG,
the late great, Sean Connery.
His immediate successor, George Lazenby,
the always classy Roger Moore.
Stage and screen veteran, Timothy Dalton,
the piercing blue eyes of Mr. Brosnan,
and a rough and tumble Daniel Craig.
All turned in stellar
performances as James Bond
in their day, but I only
have one martini to hand out,
the rest gets a splitter case
of Milwaukee's best, light.
Here's how we'll determine a winner.
Round one, box office,
round two, Tomatometer/Audience Score,
round three, villains,
and then we'll do a wild card round
that Sean Connery hopes
will involve chest hair.
The daring adventures, the smooth veneer,
the magic with the ladies.
I have none of that.
And those that can't do, judge.
Let's get it on.
- [All Together] Bond,
James Bond.
(bell rings)
- Round one,
Box office.
A new James Bond flick opening
at your local movie theater
has been a big deal since 1962,
when Mr. Connery first
appeared as 007 in Dr. No.
Sure, we're excited to see the villains,
the Bond ladies, the musical
number and the opening credits,
but it's the swab secret agent
that gets our wallets out,
and if you're gonna win
this round, volume helps.
So apologies to George
Lazenby and Timothy Dalton,
they'll be fighting an uphill battle
throughout this episode, as
they only have three Bond films
to share between them.
But it's worth noting
that both averaged over
100 million dollars
for their films at the
domestic box office,
and worldwide, George
Lazenby's lone outing as Bond
in "On Her Majesty's Secret Service"
raked in 563 million dollars.
Dalton's two films,
"The Living Daylights",
and "License to Kill"
averaged 370 million dollars
across the globe. Well done lads.
But now it's time for the big boys.
- Piss off.
- Pierce Brosnan and Daniel Craig
each have four Bond films to their credit,
although Craig's fifth is
on its way any day now,
month now, year now?
The fellas are tooth and
nail here in the States
with Craig enjoying a 257 million dollar,
DeBrosnan's 243 million dollar average.
Overseas it's an easier victory for Craig,
as he tops all James Bonds by
averaging 900 million dollars
every time he walks into frame
and does that cool turn
shoot maneuver that
I wasn't allowed to do
because they don't trust me
with weapons or even
martinis around the studio.
- Well, you gave it your best shot.
- [Mark] Perhaps the two
men best known for Bond
are sir Connery and sir Moore, in part,
because they each play
the role seven times.
Yes, we are counting Sean's
return to the character
for 1983's "Never say never again".
- Hello again.
- And while Indiana Jones's pops
can't quite get to Daniel
Craig's worldwide average,
he still earns an easy
silver medal in that event
with 757 million dollars for his average.
That's well above
Roger's, still excellent,
614 million dollars per film total.
It's actually here in the US of A
that Sean Connery fully
asserts his dominance,
whereas Roger Morris flicks took in
a respectable 180 million dollar average.
Connery clears the entire field
by almost 100 million dollars,
as his movies rang up
365 million bucks each
and every time he was on the poster.
For kicks, let's see if
any Bond films vaulted over
the mythological 1 billion dollar mark.
Yeah, they did.
Three accomplish that feat.
Skyfall was the all time
King with $1.2 billion,
edging out the two Connery flicks
to run pass the bill,
"Goldfinger" and "Thunderball".
Connery got there when
the canvas was fresh
and what a portrait he painted.
Craig and Moore proved to be competitive
but when it comes to Bond
making money at the movies,
except no substitutes,
Sean Connery wins round one
and goes up one to nothing, to nothing.
To nothing,
to nothing.
Look. There's five fellas
on the scoreboard folks,
it's gonna take a while.
- Shocking.
(groaning)
- Positively shocking.
(bell rings)
- Round two.
Tomatometer/Audience Score.
Sure, money is what I want
but you can't buy me love.
The Tomatometer doesn't
care how rich you are,
it values what's on the inside.
Are you a good movie?
- Sometimes.
- Whole new ballgame in this round,
and even George Lazenby can be a threat.
Again, he only made one
Bond movie but it's quality
over quantity here, in "On
Her Majesty's Secret Service"
gets him all the way up
to 80% on the Tomatometer.
Gentlemen, can anyone beat that?
It's a tight contest here
as all but one bond actor
enjoy fresh average onset Tomatometer.
Poor Roger Moore is-
I can't even say rotten.
He's almost fresh.
He's fresher Jason.
He averages 56.8%, but
he's still looking up
at Pierce Brosnan at 61%.
Timothy Dalton at 74.5%,
Daniel Craig at 78.7%, Lazenby
with his 80% once again
and on top, oh, that's the way I like it,
is Sean Connery with 83%.
Apologies to Connery and his family
for that impression.
So wait, is the Scottish
fella from Darby O'Gillen
"The Little People" just
going to crush everyone
in this round too?
Not so fast.
Connery's best individual
flicks are impressive
with "Goldfinger" topping
all Bond films at 98%.
But every actor who put on
the tux has at least one movie
in the Tomatometer top 10.
Daniel Craig's best is
"Casino Royale" 95%.
Lazenby has his entry at 80%,
Roger Moore has "The Spy
Who Loved Me" at 79%.
Pierce Brosnan's "Goldeneye" at 78%.
It's a great movie. it
is a better video game.
- Precisely.
And Timothy Dalton sneaks in
with "License to kill" at 77%.
It's a bleaker picture
for Brosnan and Roger Moore at the bottom.
They each have three movies
in the six most rotten bond pictures.
But hey, we did what we had to do
to get Denise Richards role
as a literal rocket scientist.
Speaking of giving the
crowd what they want,
let's move over to the audience score.
Once again, it's Roger
Moore bringing up the rear
but this time Pierce Brosnan joins him
in just south of fresh Phil.
Dalton Lazenby are on
the fresh dance floor
but can barely hear the
music and so once again,
it's Daniel Craig and Sean
Connery duking it out at the top.
And it's the most recent
still current Bond
that comes out ahead with his
collection of four movies,
sitting at 73.5% edging out
Connery's seven flicks at 70%.
It's often mentioned that Daniel Craig
has made to great Bond
films, "Casino Royale"
and "Skyfall" and then
two other Bond movies,
but those good ones are
great and they're both
in the top three of the audience score
sandwiching "Goldfinger".
Sounds delicious, but no time to eat now,
Daniel Craig wins his first round
and we got us a ballgame.
- I'm sorry, that last
hand nearly killed me.
- Round three.
Villains.
Sure, James Bond gets
the MGM roaring lion's
share of the credit but his films
are made exponentially more entertaining
by the presence of badass ladies like
Pussy Galore, Tracy Bond and Wai Lin
as well as the subject of
this round, the villains.
Yeah, if liver cirrhosis doesn't kill 007,
one of these all time baddies just might.
But which Bond faced off
against the evilest of the evil?
Sorry, Doc, not this time.
- Shit.
- In this category,
even one dynamic villain
could be enough to turn
the tide in your favor,
just ask Rick Sanchez,
the bad guy from Timothy Dalton's
"The living daylights",
haven't heard of him?
He's the one that feeds people to sharks,
and if you got more screentime
maybe he'd figure out
a way to give them improved
frickin laser beams.
- Throw me a frickin bone here.
- That's your clubhouse leader,
but here comes George
Lazenby going up against
maybe the toughest bond foe ever, Blofeld.
Played by Telly Savalas,
Blofeld set the template
for a thinking person's evildoer matching
not just wits but brains against Jimmy.
His legacy was reinvigorated
when Christophe Waltz
portrayed an updated version
going up against Daniel Craig
in his multiple bond flicks.
It's a chess game where
the nefarious genius
always seems two steps ahead,
and maybe that's because
Craig could barely recover
from another great bad dude
with a physical defect,
The blood weeping Washifra,
played by Mads Mickelson.
Is he related to Phil?
Anybody have that answer?
How's his short game?
- That's it?
- But if you want a treasure trove of sin,
head over to the 1970s and
revisit the Roger Moore era.
Not only was Christopher Lee
an amazing devious presence
in "Star Wars", "Lord of
the Rings" and "Dracula",
his turn as Francisco Scaramanga
in "a Man with the Golden Gun",
legitimize his and otherwise
rather silly 007 entry.
Japheth Kodo's Mr. Big,
and Christopher Walkin's Max Zorin,
were also memorable, but
it's Richard keels jaws
that makes more a potent
threat to take this round.
The metal mouth seemingly indestructible
yet surprisingly emotional
narrative do well
appeared in both "The Spy Who Loved Me"
and "Moonraker", and just
might take the trophy
for Bond villain that we're
secretly pulling for kinda.
I know he's bad, but he's irresistible.
- Here's to us.
- Sean Connery will make
some noise here as well
as his Bond film "Goldfinger"
is the rare double duty doozy
of being both the movie
title and a villain.
- Do you expect me to talk?
- No Mr. Bond I expect you to die.
We also got odd job in that classic
but it was the original Bond movie
that set the template
for baddies so deviant
we named the flick after them.
Dr. No catapulted movie antagonists
to new eccentric heights
and set the trend for the
elaborate dress, plans
and evil wears.
- A unique feat of
engineering if I may say so,
I designed it myself.
- But if you're like me and love jaws.
No, no, not you, we're
talking about the movie now.
Possibly your favorite
bond foil is Red Grant
played by Quint himself, Robert Shaw.
Not only does he make
"From Russia with Love"
one of the most enjoyable spy movies ever,
Esquire ranked him as the
best Bond baddie in history.
Connery also squared off
against the original incarnation
of Blofeld, played by Donald Pleasance,
but to me, this round
belongs to Roger Moore's
unique array of villains that
boasts diversity of thought,
tactics, intelligence and quirks.
Unless Pierce Brosnan wants to swoop in-
- What? No small talk?
No chitchat?
- He does make a case
with "Goldeneye" as both Shawn Beam
and Fomka Jansen make terrific villains,
but after that, as much
as I love Jonathan Price,
the bad guys just can't compete.
This round belongs to Roger Moore's 007,
and now our tie at the top is a three way.
- Original. What will they think of next?
- And now it's time for
our wildcard round gadgets.
Yep, that's right.
It's the round that throws
a monkey into the wrench,
a twist into the fate and
a shake into the martini.
Which Bond is bringing the
best gadgets to his mission?
Every 007 film features tons
of fun technological toys,
so I'll stick with each
player's very best of the best.
These are my favorite gaggle of gadgets
from the one and only cue,
shout out to the late great Desmond Lewin,
who portrayed the role of
Bond's genius sidekick the most,
and to John Cleese and Hugh dancy
who've made the role their own sense.
All right, let's explode some pens.
- Oh grow up 007.
- This might be the only
round where Sean Connery
is at somewhat of a disadvantage
because his golden Bond
years were back in the 1960s.
However, he still gets
to show off some gear
that would make Boba Fett blush.
We'll get this jet pack in "Thunderball".
I'm also a fan of the cigarette gun,
but both those things are dangerous, kids.
From "You Only Live Twice" and a suitcase
that probably inspired that
mariachi from Desperado
in "From Russia with love".
Roger Moore's avant garde 70s
approach to both his fashion
and tech up the ante as we
were introduced to everything
from a wrist gun to a
bug detecting shaver.
You know, for those hard to reach places
where you might have bugs.
But if I'm highlighting
one technological marvel
from Moore's run, it's a watch.
They can also be a saw.
Oh, did we mention it's a Rolex?
Yeah, go back and
revisit "Living Let Die".
Now I like the Guns and Roses version
over Paul McCartney's hot take,
but there is no way to
improve upon a wristwatch,
they can also help you build a deck.
Good luck replicating that one, apple.
Pierce Brosnan scores some major points
for his GoldenEye exploding pen.
But in his later films, the
gadgets tried a little too hard
to pay homage to the goofier 70s.
- So, this is where they
keep the old relics?
- We had a disappearing
car, the X ray glasses.
It was fun, do not get me wrong,
but it also made clear
that this Bond iteration
was only going to get
sillier and more ridiculous
even as Pierce did his
best to add legitimacy
to the zaniness surrounding it.
So exit Remington Steele
and enter layer cake.
- We were expecting an exploding pen.
We didn't really go in for that anymore.
- Daniel Craig's 007
robot is much on his fist
and the occasional headbutt
as much as any previous super spy,
but he still had some clutch gadgetry
that helped literally keep him alive.
The defibrillator
narrowly avoided his death
in his very first 007 outing.
We also saw sweet explosive key chain,
which is classic bond,
and then in "Specter",
we saw some scientific
tomfoolery with the smart blood.
Also let's not overlook
the return of the Aston
Martin in "Skyfall".
People lost their minds in the theater
when it was revealed.
Even me who questionably
prefers Pierce Brosnan's
Zippy BMW Z3 from "Goldeneye".
After that movie came out,
it became the midlife crisis card elise,
move over Mazda Miata,
there's a new tiny sheriff in town.
The BMW Z3, perfect for saving the world
from evil geniuses and run by fritters.
Every bun has a cool car, great
gadgets and fists of fury,
including George Lazenby,
who will unfortunately
taken an L in this round
simply due to the lack of a tech resume.
- This never happened to the other fella.
But what his one movie lacks
in Geek Squad know how,
he makes up for with
actual fighting ability.
His martial arts on the beach
and "On Her Majesty's Secret
Service" are impressive.
So maybe he didn't care
about the more modern toys.
Folks who do their yoga
claim their bodies a temple,
Lazenby's Bond body was a gadget,
and he wielded it with vengeance.
That leaves Timothy Dalton
who would seem to be limited
by his mere two films in the world of 007,
but those flicks came out in the 1980s
and thus presented the best mixture
of classic bond gadget necessity
with futuristic tech ridiculousness.
His Aston Martin come standard
with a rocket launcher,
and he also has a ride that
could ski down mountains.
Plus every great vehicle
needs an exploding key fob
and his license to kill
signature gun is pure,
unfiltered 007 mythology.
Dalton ended up turning
down a contract extension
after a prolonged legal
battle over the rights
to James Bond movies, but his two entries
added so much to the Bond gadget portfolio
that we wanted to see more.
And in the end, that's
enough to get him a surprise
winning the wild card round,
meaning it's a one to
one to one to zero tie.
- Wherever she was must have scared
the living daylights out of her.
- Hell of an effort by all six gentlemen.
An honorable mention goes to the 1967
"Casino Royale" star, David Nibin.
George Lazenby came into a top decision
as he followed a legend in the making
in Sean Connery, but he
adjudicated himself well
and kept the franchise afloat
for Roger Moore to come in
and give us the next great era.
And props to Pierce
whose "Goldmine" may be
one of the most important films
in the entire legacy of Bond.
Without his name, power
and the vintage Bond feel
of that movie, we may not be referring
to 007 as a present day
force at the cinemas.
But Lazenby and Brosnan
couldn't muster quite enough
to win a round today,
so now my decision for the winner
works between Connery,
Moore, Dalton and Craig.
And speaking of rounds,
let's make grownup
hydration the tiebreaker.
Our own expert researcher Mark Hoffmeyer,
who I would say is the cue of this show,
except he looks much
better in a suit than I do,
referred me to the
economist who broke down
all the on camera drinks
James Bond has consumed.
The most exercise liver of
the bunch goes to Daniel Craig
with 22 total cocktails.
Connery is second with 16,
and Moore follows closely with 14.
And for me, I want my Bonds
brand to be well lubricated,
but also sober enough
to pull off the mission,
which is why Sean Connery is
still my ultimate James Bond.
We only lost him recently
but he got a head start on everyone else
and never looked back.
- So, do you lose as
gracefully as you win?
- I wouldn't know, I've never lost.
- It's Connery's mix of masculine swab,
rough handsomeness and
pitch perfect one liners
that sealed the deal for me.
Some of the content in his
era hasn't aged all that well,
but Mr. Connery in the suit is timeless.
Unlike this vid, which could be outdated
as soon as I see Daniel
Craig's last stand as 007.
Maybe he returns to "Skyfall" forum,
in which case I'd have
to return to the studio
and rent this from Men's Warehouse again
to reconsider my take.
So while that keeps me up at night,
we leave it to you, dear viewer,
to weigh in on the subject
and let us know your
favorite Bond of all time.
You can hit me up anytime
at Mark Ellis live,
and while you're at it, show MI6
that you care by subscribing
to Rotten Tomatoes on YouTube
and checking out rottentomatoes.com.
Thanks for watching, and I
do believe it's time for me
to also have a drink that
is shaken, not stirred.
In which case I'll then have to clean up
all the course light that
explodes out of the can.
(upbeat music)